sales guys come up to me and they're  like dude i got 25 grand you know i'm  feeling pretty good so i'm just like  curious what kind of investments should  i be getting into crypto's looking  pretty good right now and it drives me  nuts because i'm pretty sure i didn't  have any money in my bank account at any  time until i had a million dollars in my  bank account within a couple months the  reason for that was because my belief is  that you should spend all of the money  that you have to acquire skills until  you can't spend money on acquiring  skills anymore and you can pretty much  always spend money to acquire skills  it's users do it differently and so like  the higher up you go now i have to make  donations to charities in hundreds and  millions of dollars in order to get  access to the boards of these charities  who are other dudes who can donate  hundreds of thousands and millions of  dollars to this charity so that i can  then see what they know so that i can  learn faster